hmm
Satoshi
why is this so significant
how many times previously has there been
a massive anonymous selfless spiritual
code deployment that has augmented
civilization
hmm
how many times in history has it been
that people took massive burdens on
their backs and had divine things
channeled through them so that they
could leave the world a tremendously
better off place I love that that story
is so beautiful it's a gorgeous story of
sacrifice for the greater good
and it also avoids serious complications
because if the augmentations to
civilization are done for the purposes
of money or fame
that it's inevitably corrupted so doing
it completely selflessly doing it
anonymously and doing it in a way that
transcends our own ego and our own time
just like so many of the mega structures
that have been built by so many people
of our past transcended the individual
for the collective
I think there is a beautiful balance to
strike between the actualization of the
self and that Nash equilibrium of the
collective prospering as well
all right let's talk about this most
recent one and why it's so important
we've had a tremendous amount of
centralization that has
especially since the Industrial
Revolution been happening and the
potential for decentralization
technologies ones that can be truly
decentralized truly distributed and
truly immutable on a ledger that's being
kept in such a gorgeous way that is
still being built up on to see if it can
become better and more efficient over
time
has been one of the most awakening
augmentations to civilization in the
last decade
and this is way beyond money and
cryptocurrency way beyond that way
beyond smart contracts this is
in many ways how the individual
interfaces with the society that it
lives in is critical to that fabric and
in many ways also speaks to the way that
creation occurred in the first place in
a very very interconnected way so what
is so important about this why is a
method like the Satoshi method of
anonymous selfless spiritual code
deployments that augment civilization
why is that so important
I think the first and really deeply feel
the first most important aspect to it is
that it truly transits transcends us
then if it is done that way if the
update is truly anonymous and selfless
then it truly is not there for ego or
for fame or for greed the corruptive
tendencies dissipate if we do it for the
purpose of the greater good and I think
that's gorgeous and many people
recognize it as gorgeous now of course
we must also say that we are not sure if
this Satoshi is an individual if it's
all collective if it's an AI if it was
downloaded from something greater than
an individual into an individual all
these types of things so when these
things happen
even when we do things like build this
show we frequently remind ourselves that
these the show is not for ourselves it's
not for our own egos it's not for our
own Fame it's not for our own fortunes
is for other people every single piece
of content every single moment of time
that we put into this show is for other
people to help them develop themselves
and develop a better world that essence
carrying that essence with you through
all that you do in the world on a
moment-to-moment basis
your actions transcending you for the
greater good is so such a beautiful
mentality to carry and if you do that
for these massive massive spiritual
deployments that occur like something
like a blockchain technology which I
hope to see more and more of
these styles of deployments of
augmenting our social fabric which is
why we're making this piece of content
right now so that more people say hmm
what is this Satoshi method and why is
it such an interesting way to deploy an
update to our world well think about how
many times it has been that people fight
over their deployments to our world it's
visible everywhere monetarily with Fame
corruption patents geopolitical warfare
mimetic propaganda it's visible
everywhere and to do it in a way that
transcends us for the greater good it
literally resonates into every single
person's heart that has the feeling
capacity and I was awakened enough to to
feel it and to understand why that that
person or that organization is deploying
the updates in the way it is in an
anonymous way something as profound as
decentralization technologies it's
gorgeous
I really do strongly feel that by making
this piece of content as well as
spreading this meme of the Satoshi
method I think and feel that we have the
potential to see in the 2020s 2030s and
onward a tremendous amount of people
that are willing to put aside ego money
Fame and deploy these updates in ways
that are selfless anonymous and
spiritual for our world and then one of
the one of the best parts is that you
get out of the vortex one of the things
that is corrupting the way that people
update the world is that they get sucked
into the Joker vortex all of the stuff
that is talk all the stuff that's talked
about on the internet all the time
people tagging you wanting rip
answers all that stuff if you deploy the
idea anonymously into the world well
then the idea itself is what gets
critiqued people don't go for the person
right now we see so much people going
after a person and their previous life
history saying that they did something
five years ago ten years ago fifteen
years ago that was unethical even though
their ethics have evolved and they say
that they made a mistake they said we
still see people going back so by taking
ourselves out of the picture and letting
the idea be deployed into the world we
let the idea speak for itself and then
people to work on that idea critique the
idea make the idea better
that type of stuffs exactly what's
happening with the decentralization
technology movement that has been
roaring the last couple years it's
gorgeous but there is also a very small
balance of some nuance that we you know
Alan knew on sake on that we need to
bring up which is that one of the also
beauties of deploying some sort of an
update into the world is that if there
is someone that stands behind the idea
it has a greater chance in sometimes in
likely almost certainly of going forth
and propagating further so if
something's asked profound as
decentralization technology started in
such a small small niche and then all of
a sudden boom now it's in so many places
in the world well it's not always
guaranteed that that meme without
someone that's really backing it and
decentralization technologies had a
community of blockchain and
cryptocurrency developers that were
pushing it forward but that is the thing
is that there needs to still be some
people that push the meme forward and so
how do you do that well in an anonymous
deployment the people can push the meme
forward as a community and if you do
choose to deploy it non anonymously with
your name behind it well then you get
the benefit of doing things like
learning how to stay really
Boal as you go and speak about this
social flat fabric deployment that
you're aiming to augment our world with
and so you can do things like travel and
teach about it and stay humble stay
humble stay humble as you do it it's so
so important so that's the tiny bit of
nuance around it as well keep
propagating the meme of these code
updates but do it in a way that is if
you put a name behind it humble and
still spiritual and transcendent but if
you don't put your name behind it do it
in a way that ensures that a community
can still carry it forward that
deployment so I hope that more and more
people get talking about the beauty of
the Satoshi method and how it is truly
selfless it's truly spiritual truly
anonymous and also has been a massive
inspiration for so many of us to do that
same style of code employment that
augments our world thank you very much
for tuning in go and share and talk more
with your friends families co-workers
people online about things like this get
talking more about it and let's see what
other code deployments can be done in
this similar fashion much love thank you
for tuning in dr. Soong